now u.s president trump is on his way
out
and his successor is preparing to take
over experts
are wondering though what will remain of
trump's policies take trade for example
especially trade with
china central to trump's america first
approach where policies to reduce
the us's trade deficit with china
he introduced tariffs on 360 billion
dollars worth
of chinese-made products but that seems
to have failed in its aim
in november china's global trade surplus
skyrocketed to over 75 billion
dollars most of that was led by the us
where exports to the u.s were up 46
on a year ago in november the main
reason for that is of course the
coronavirus pandemic with
many americans stuck at home record
amounts are being spent on
a huge range of chinese products
meanwhile
american exports to china have improved
but only
slightly agricultural products have sold
well but
manufactured items have been badly hit
by the pandemic
so let's discuss this with laura von
daniels from the german institute for
international
and security affairs swp welcome to dw
business great to have you on the
program so it goes against
donald trump's stated aims this
increased deficit
but is it actually a problem for the
united states
um yes it is a problem uh in in terms of
improving the trade balance because at
least that's what's been promised to
americans for more than four years now
and yeah you might say that raging a
trade war against china
and even reaching something like the
phase one trade agreement with china
earlier this year in february
didn't really improve anything about the
trade balance so maybe
that wasn't the right metric to begin
with
how much can governments actually do
though because in this case we've seen
that
the consumers have essentially had the
final say
that's true maybe they cannot do so much
about it after all
as i said before
raging a trade war didn't really change
the situation
and well some people say this is just uh
the consequence of the pandemic because
people started to
use their extra liquidity not for
services as they usually do for travel
and so on but they put it in
they channeled it to consumer goods more
than they would have otherwise
um but you know this has been a trend
for more than
uh this year so it's been going on for a
while so
you know the question really is how much
a government can steer trade relations
yes not so much exactly is can this
can this current trend last really so
we've got
president-elect biden taking office next
month
do we know if he's got a radically
different approach to china
well he's been critical of china he's
criticized
its uh theft of intellectual property
and his uh china's subsidies policy and
other
difficult areas and in trade relations
but you might as well see him
trying to to reach some kind of
rapprochement with the chinese i think
it's it's probably among the possible
options
to see the u.s negotiate over at least
limited trade agreement with china again
and to rebuild relations that were
harmed by the trump administration
seriously harmed
all right laura von daniels from the
german institute for
international and security affairs thank
you very much for joining us here on b
on dw business thanks for having me